all right good morning everyone you all
got out of bed you've all found your way
here it's a challenge sometimes with
some of the conference centers in europe
today's talk is a hundred thousand
different ways to manage secrets in get
ops
my name is andrew block i am a
distinguished architect with red hat uh
i have been working in the get off space
for a lot of a good amount of time been
part working part of the working group
that the team mentioned earlier today uh
i do specialize in not only ci cd but
also security
and automation
uh i have two books out there one of
them is called learn helm
the second one which is coming out
in august is securing kubernetes secrets
so
be on the lookout for that and a little
bit of a easter egg a little later on
the presentation coming up so keep on
look out for that i am also a helm
maintainer so really interested in the
helm ecosystem understanding how
applications are managed in a kubernetes
environment so
get us principles
they have they apply to a variety of
contexts they apply to your
infrastructure this is going to be
their your vms your static machines
they're also going to apply to your
applications they're going to be you
know database credentials configurations
you name it but they also apply to cloud
and now non-cloud assets yes get ops can
apply to non-cloud assets
how many of you have servers in your
data center raise your hand
okay
you can still apply get up there it's
not only for the cloud
where are the different ways that you
can manage get ops you can first manage
them you have to then manage them on
your local machine these are going to be
using command line tools they're going
to be technically definitely part of
your your ci cd process so they're going
to be
in your pipelines and how you manage
them we'll go into some of the details a
little later on and then most
importantly they're going to be in your
operating environment where you're
actually using your get ops
principles your values how are they
being used
you need to understand where and how
they're being used
so
your get ops typically involves the use
of sensitive assets where are those
sensitive assets coming from where they
relate to first of all they're your
source code repositories you typically
need to talk to a git repository or some
other source code to be able to
implement git ops
next is infrastructure management how
are you connecting to these individual
machines that you're trying to target
third is application configurations as i
mentioned previously you're going to
have your database password you're going
to have your external resources where
are they coming from certificate
management those are all areas that you
need to be very confident about when
operating in production and then finally
access to platform resources so if
you're talking to aws google kubernetes
you typically need to authenticate in
some form or another you typically have
to then manage that through git or some
related system
however most importantly
improper management of get ops can have
very serious consequences and how
serious can they be well
first of all what is managing get ops
the wrong way
number one we've talked about it earlier
today
do not in any way put password sensitive
material you name it
as plain text into git
because as soon as you commit it to get
it's there forever
in most cases
uh also be confident about the tooling
that you're working with
understand that if you put passwords
are they going to save in plain text are
they going to be encrypted what does
your tool support
and then next understand the limitations
of your tooling so if they don't store
them in
encrypted values or sensitive or you
know protected resources understand
those understand just the limitations of
what your tool can provide this goes
beyond git it's any type of feature of
your tool and then
don't do security theater how many of
you are familiar with security theater
what is it
anybody it's basically going in and
abstracting security even though you're
not really being secure i'm going to go
ahead and encode something 18 times
you're not really making it secure you
can just decrypt it you know decode it
18 times
that's security theater
so what are some of the implications of
improper secrets management number one
time and effort
if you're going to go ahead and not only
implement it but do it the wrong way
that's just wasted time but if you do it
or just partly don't do it and you get
caught or there's a breach there's going
to be a lot of pain to have to unwield
all that back you're going to have to
not only
fix your get repository if you're
working in github gitlab you got to go
call them because guess what they
they're gonna have to have you help you
scrub the data if you have forks while
you're in big trouble because that means
that all your forked repositories are
now you know compromised it's a lot of
work to be able to come back from from a
breach next is career
repercussions or
if you want it could be a career resume
building opportunity if you want but in
most cases you wouldn't want that
uh financial implications if it happens
to cause a negative impact on your
organization you're working for you may
be sanctioned or fined
based on the repercussions and then find
finally brand casualty you know we all
know of a lot of organizations these
days that have had security breaches
i won't name them but
in the security space we all now know of
certain companies that we had no idea
that existed before what they did
there's a reason why they now we now
know about them
so most importantly what are the proper
ways to manage
and handle secrets in get ops
so there are three areas that i'm going
to touch upon
one is how you store your sensitive data
two is how you access the sensitive data
the secrets and three once you have
access to them how do you consume them
so when you're storing secrets there are
two primary ways that you will go ahead
and put those into your git repository
one you will encrypt the values
you know you'll store then you'll use
some tool encrypt them and store the
encrypted values inside your git
repository the second one is to use an
external reference you're going to take
the sensitive resources store it
somewhere else but just put a pointer
inside your git repository so that when
you when you're reconciling your state
some other tool is going to be able to
go ahead and reach out to some external
system and find it at run time
so
the good news is there's a lot of tools
out there to implement or to store
secrets
the bad news is there's a lot of tools
out there to store secrets
which tool is the right one
i'm i'm an architect and a consultant my
answer always is
it depends
but
there's a lot of options out here i
always say see what your organization
feels the most comfortable with
some are in the cloud some are not you
have you know you know hashicorp vault
is a corporate option you know that has
self-hosted and cloud management if
you're in one of the three major cloud
providers each one of them has a secrets
management tool you also have the ci
tools github get lab they also offer
secrets management capabilities you have
options out there see which one makes
the most sense for you and your
organization
one of the benefits is some of these
tools do offer dual capabilities of
being a kms so you can take advantage of
the key management facilities provided
by these tools azure is one of them
so when you're storing values in your
repository there are certain traits that
you're typically are involved one
they're most likely going to be either
cli or gui based you know capabilities
uh they do enable these these cli tools
to encrypt and both decrypt at the same
time
and i'll say it again
this applies to kubernetes now we're all
here at kubecon and in in cncfcon
it still applies to non-kubernetes
environments so even though you may not
be in kubernetes still applies
there are tools out there for you to
store your secrets a big one out there
is sops
another one is the sealed secrets
project so if you're using that there's
a command line tool called cubevale
there are also other tools that are not
really kubernetes specific which are
ansible vault of using ansible for
automation and helm if you're using helm
for package management for kubernetes it
also has a tooling that you can use to
integrate secrets management into the
helm ecosystem
the second option is storing those
values externally
where do you typically store those
values externally one well if you're
using in your ci infrastructure you're
going to use the jenkins there's there's
secrets management capabilities and
jenkins you're going to have github
actions gitlab there are each one of
them has a facility for secrets
management
next is platform infrastructure you're
going to have your is solution your open
stacks it has a secrets management tool
your paths solution might have one
kubernetes has a secret to management
we'll go into the a little bit later but
it also has one out there and then as i
mentioned previously if you're using a
cloud service there are options there as
well for integrating and storing secrets
inside one of those platforms
so
how do i reference that once i go ahead
and store something how do i reference
them so typically you only want to store
the referenceable values inside your
repository what are you actually storing
in that repository well there are two
primary error primary ways of doing it
one is placeholder values
or platforms of specific values so a
placeholder value is gonna be like an
environment variable however if you're
in a certain platform there might be
certain default values that come out of
the box like for github action this
could be secrets dot whatever the name
of the value that you stored inside the
platform so it depends on what operating
environment you're currently working in
so that's number one number two is how
do i access my values once i've stored
them i'm good at storing but can i
access them
so three things that we need to talk
about one which tools are available for
us to be able to access our secrets
what is the access model that we should
implement and employ when trying to
access those secrets and three
you know once we we do have to think a
little bit ahead how are these secrets
going to be consumed because
if we understand how they're going to be
consumed it may determine how we want to
access them
so
there are various tools out there for us
to be able to leverage they're number
one as very similar to how we stored our
secrets we can access them via command
line tools you have the aws cli you have
cube veil if you want to use cl secrets
there's a lot of tools out there if
you're using cube ctl you can go ahead
and retrieve the values that way as well
those tools can be standalone or they
can be integrated into other tooling
now cicd tools like jenkins github you
name it has comparable tools to be able
to access the values
you you have a c you have the for github
you have the github cli
but most people myself included will
just use the ui which is how i am
ci is great because it also accelerates
to get the devsec ops process because
you're also starting to get security
involved throughout the process
how many of you are have looked into
devsecops at all in your organization
how many you are planning on using
devstuck ops
how many of you have no idea what
devstuck ops is
devsecops really is an extension of
devops in a way to get security closer
we're going to shift it to the left and
have security be part of the
conversation up front get your security
team involved because as i've worked
with many organizations over time
you can get close to production and then
oh the security guy comes in and says oh
you need to make sure you implement this
or fill out this form and then you have
to go back and either redesign something
delay the process of getting security
involved is very important at the
forefront
finally is plugins for tooling
there's a lot of plugins out there to
integrate secret utilities they are
either exist extensions of existing
systems and they also abstract and
support the life cycle of secrets
management
there are plugins for cube cube ctl and
helm helm has an extensive plug-in
system kubernetes has one as well and
also there are package managers
specifically designed for plug-ins how
many of you have heard of crew for q for
kubernetes
it's a plug-in management system for
kubernetes plugins it's pretty cool
check it out
and if you haven't played around with
these cli plugins the way to do so is to
use you know the tool which is basically
cube ctl the name of the plugin and then
any sub commands that be that can be
part of the plugin so if you have a cube
now cube you know cube ctl secrets
management
extract encrypt decrypt i'm throwing
something out there it's just the
typical convention of how these tools
are integrated
now i mentioned kubernetes there are
solutions purposely built around the
ecosystem of kubernetes
to integrate secrets management one is
standard controllers kubernetes has
hundreds of controllers built in and
extension throughout the community
these are ones that
manage different resources and react to
resources within kubernetes
you can go ahead and use a controller to
apply configurations to
values that are based on the
configurations of the resources in
kubernetes
second is web hooks now this is where
the dynamic nature of kubernetes comes
in you're able to provide either
validating or mutating web hooks to
change the composition of your
deployments or other manifest as they're
being created so
a good example is hashicorp vault and
their sidecar injector they install a
mutating webfoot configuration when a
pod comes up and it is or a deployment
is comes up and is annotated with
certain values the validating and
mutating web hook will go in and say hey
i see that value it has a reference to
secrets in vault and how to connect to
it with credentials etc it's going to go
ahead and reconfigure the deployment
add configurations to it that make the
lifecycle of managing secrets easier
third is operators and i always want to
keep operators and controllers separate
people say well it's an operator or
controller yes it is a controller an
operator is distinct because there is a
custom resource definition that it
tracks against so you would define your
configuration against that custom
resource definition and that controller
the operator would go ahead and
reconcile based upon that configuration
that's the key thing so that's a great
way that you can manage secrets and
we're going to talk to we're going to
talk through at least one or two
projects that implement their own custom
resource definition for you to then
implement secrets management
so let's talk about the three that i
always use in the kubernetes ecosystem
one is steel secret seal secrets is
probably the easiest fastest way to get
started with secrets management in
kubernetes it it provides a controller
with its own private key that allows you
to encrypt and decrypt sensitive values
however in
practice i have seen that it there are
limitations to sealed secrets in this
multi-tenancy so be on the lookout it's
great to start with it's great for small
projects but if you have a large team
that is using it in a large environment
it's multi-tenant it can be a challenge
because you have one secret key for the
cluster
a project which i do love external
secrets so if you're using an external
secrets management tool a cloud provider
secret management tool
hashtag vault you name it
this allows you to integrate a
controller to grab resources and access
and manage those resources
into kubernetes and then finally a third
option out there in kubernetes that i
see
widely being adopted is the vault
secrets agent injector which which is a
great feature-rich plug-in for hashicorp
vaults it allows you to inject sidecars
into
deployments and pods as they need to you
can also then manage the entire life
cycle of secrets within your kubernetes
cluster so if you're synchronizing
secrets from hashtag vault and you
change them in vault it will actually go
in and periodically refresh the state
automatically and the same thing when it
comes to your containers too really cool
project as well
all three here are great ones to
implement so on the right is an example
of how you reference an external secret
to reference of vault from
aws we're going to go ahead and
apparently uh it's going part it's going
to be in high school vault referencing
credentials to talk to aws so it's going
to be a hashtag vault
it's basically saying in the backend
type is going to be vault
we're going to say we want to go ahead
and reference the aws key id and the
um secret id
in secret key pardon me inside vault and
it's going to put that in a secret
um in your um in your kubernetes cluster
uh how many of you are using any one of
these tools right now
that's good i mean it's either not a
good adoption and b you are using
secrets management tools and get up so
that's great to see validation from the
community here
third is the get ops engine
kubernetes has
really
moved forward how git ops tooling works
two common projects out there are one
flux
and two argo cd for implementing get ops
it's not the only ones they're just the
two most popular ways of implementing
get ops in kubernetes
if you're using flux it has integrated
soft functionality and by using fl softs
you can then integrate an external
secrets management tool
very easily or you can use a p a gpg pgp
because soft also supports that as well
if you're using
argo cd there's an entire plugin system
that argo cd provides and there's a
vault secrets management plugin for argo
cd so if you're using argo cd you can
now integrate hashtag vault very easily
two great options two doesn't really
matter what tooling you're using to
allow you to operate successfully and
securely inside kubernetes
next
well we need to access the credentials
what are some considerations that you
need to have
when
setting up how you're accessing those
values one
understanding
what options and
capabilities are provided by the tools
you're using you're actually using
identify security boundaries
ensure that you only create
credentials and access models that are
for your application only don't go ahead
and create a single principle that's
going to use it for all your
applications across your entire
portfolio that's just a breach waiting
to happen because one breach happens you
have to go ahead and basically rotate
your entire ecosystem
watch out
so recommendations for that one of them
as i mentioned use that dedicated
service principle
two short-lived credentials try to use
them as short as possible have rotation
on them don't go ahead and create a
credential today and i come back next
year or we see all you all in detroit
i don't want to have you talk to you and
say i'm using the same credentials
we need to have a talk at that point
it's a fun talk
and then as i mentioned emphasize that
least privilege principle only create
credentials for individual resources if
i have application a create a principle
for application a if i have application
b create a set principle for application
b
what are some common access methods for
talking and accessing your secrets one
the simplest basic auth
it is what it is they're just an option
out there two most common out there is
bear token that's how you can talk to
kubernetes one of the ways you can talk
to kubernetes three which is really cool
assumed identity oidc how many of you
are integrating oidc for how you're
accessing your sensitive values
awesome
awesome oidc is great so if you're using
github actions in aws and get left
they're now starting to support oidc for
you to access external resources you
don't have to have and store secrets you
can use assumed identities on the
platform if you have any questions on
this is a kind of a complex topic it's
really emerging i'm happy to sit down
and talk to you about it i'm part of
another project called six store we use
that extensively in the six store
projects so oidc and student identity
look into it if you haven't you may not
be able to leverage it because your
tooling and operating environment may
not support it now but at least keep it
in the back of your mind is a great way
to manage secrets management in security
okay we talked about how we store the
secrets how we access them
now the most important part how do we
actually use them you know because you
know we did all the two of the three
let's go ahead and start consuming them
that's two common ways that you will
consume secrets in your git ops process
one
environment variables you're going to
consume whatever it happens to be
as environments variables and number two
through a file system
and the simplest way to do that is a
kubernetes secret that's pretty much the
de facto way of storing secret values
and sensitive values in kubernetes
however i will emphasize
over and over this week
there are limitations to kubernetes
secrets
they are base64 encoded base64 encoding
is not a security mechanism
don't think it is you can extract you
can basically decrypt that in about four
seconds not even four seconds tens of
seconds don't even bother it's a great
way to get started but just great for
development or your local machine
not for production at all
so
some ways that you can consume secrets
one of the most common ways to do that
is a side car use a side car inside your
kubernetes pod this is kubernetes
specific configurations you have a
co-located container within your pod
that will manage the life cycle of a
secret an init container will go in and
can
communicate with an external secret
store and provide those values for your
application at startup
or
in addition to a container is a side car
that is always running in addition to
your operating container this is great
if you have a secret that may rotate
frequently and you want to be able to
synchronize that state inside your
container it will periodically go and
talk to your secrets management tool
many secrets management tool has a bit
of an overlap in time where both secrets
are valid which allows you to update the
secrets and have the new one take now be
active while the old one is still active
and then after a short amount of time
the obama will become deactivated so
that your applications will have gotten
the chance to then take action and start
utilizing the new value
if you're using a secret a sidecar
paradigm you're going to typically mount
a shared volume using an empty dir in
kubernetes they'll be shared between the
init container the sidecar container and
your operating container that they both
can read
one of the best ways to manage secrets
in that model that's the most secure is
to load your sensitive values in memory
read the read the value from the file
system remove it then start your
container up and basically start your
application up so that it's only
available at that initial initialization
point and is removed immediately so if
someone gets a session inside your
container
they can't actually access it if it's
stored in memory within your application
and this as i mentioned is a very common
pattern to the vault
sidecar
another one aside from sidecar is the
kubernetes csi driver this is a good pro
a project that has really emerged
in the open source and kubernetes
ecosystem recently it basically allows
you to
not use secrets not store your sensitive
data as
secret values inside kubernetes but
allows you to mount a volume using the
typical in you know
supported volume types and kubernetes
to be able to manage secrets
it supports multiple back-ends the
common back-ends that you're going to
have in most operating environments aws
azure gcp
vault
you can also if you're a developer
create your own it's extensible i'm a
developer i love developing and hacking
on things so if you have some other tool
that your organization is using that may
not you know be one of these three one
of these four or five you can create
your own
and then as i mentioned
it it avoids storing sensitive assets as
secrets it will either store it'll store
it within a volume in the container
there is an option in
the csi plugin
to enable it so it will synchronize to a
secret if your
tooling does require it so there is that
option to do both store it as a csi
volume but also synchronize it as a
typical traditional secret in kubernetes
and to implement that what does that
process look like three steps one
like we talked about earlier we gotta
store the value somewhere
configure the access how how is the csi
driver gonna talk to it
two we're gonna create a secret provider
class this is going to basically use and
specify the specific provider that will
talk to your backend and then any
parameters that are needed by it so it's
going to be if it's talking to vault the
location within vault that that value is
stored the location within azure secret
manager tool where it's stored et cetera
et cetera
and then within your kubernetes
deployment manifest you're going to put
you're going to specify the volume type
of csi
reference the driver you know the csi
driver and then specify the secret value
secret provider class that you specified
in step two there is your connection
from step one connects to step two to
step three
this is how you really emphasize how you
access it in a secure way within
kubernetes
i'm going to close with preventative
measures
admit it how many of you have committed
secrets to get
don't raise your hand
raise your hand if you haven't
you lie
we've all done it i've done it i've had
to call github a few times i've gotten a
couple nasty grams from my organization
saying you know we noticed something
inside your repository there um kind of
little talk
you call them up you feel shame it's all
donuts you have to go in and
do all the stuff we talked about earlier
good news there are tools there to
help you detect when secrets are present
three of them that i found that have
been very useful out there the tech
secrets project that the yelp team has
put together
aws has its own secret to management
detection tool
also in addition github and aws has
scanning utilities that are out there
already scanning repositories so github
right now if you committed aws secret
it will probably be revoked
automatically
um because there are tools out there to
tech detect when those are an aws secret
try it out you know just for
in a lab environment testing not in
production just see how that actually
works
and the great part about this is the
security become is becoming more
mainstream front and center so more of
these tools are starting to become
available so keep on the lookout for
more ways of being preventative to
ensure you have are protected
in your get out secrets management and
then finally i will close saying that
security is continuous
it's never finished you what you store
today might be vulnerable tomorrow
always make sure you incorporate
security from the start
implement across your entire
organization just don't have it be in
your little silo make sure you emphasize
security throughout every single part of
your organization revise and remediate
as necessary what happened two years ago
in the ecosystem is typical is totally
not the same as it is today the secure
software supply chain is mainstream
today i guarantee it was nothing two
years ago
and then finally identify everything you
need to do
i want to thank you for the opportunity
today hopefully you learned a lot i'm
happy to answer any questions i'll be
here all week thank you for the time
today
[Applause]